cruce esa línea con china jacusa Estados
Unidos de estar provocando al gobierno
de piquín con visitas como la de Nancy
pelosi con su delegación de congresistas
a Taiwán lo ha dicho Vladimir Putin en
una rueda de prensa en la que también ha
criticado el interés de Estados Unidos
en prolongar el conflicto de Ucrania
Putin ha dicho que los países
occidentales están buscando extender un
sistema similar al de la otan en Asia
Pacífico el libro está más un discurso
de bienvenida la conferencia de
seguridad internacional de Moscú y allí
ha criticado a la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes de Estados
Unidos
Nancy pelosi ha dicho que su visita fue
una provocación cuidadosamente
planificada anti occidental se ha sumado
también el ministro de defensa seguí soy
gu que ha dicho que Estados Unidos y
Gran Bretaña son los que están detrás de
toda la planificación de las operaciones
del ejército ucraniano también ha dicho
que Rusia no tiene ninguna intención de
utilizar armas nucleares en Ucrania Pero
ha avisado de que la entrada en la otan
de Finlandia y Suecia provocará que haya
un cambio en las prioridades defensivas
de Rusia